(gentle music)
- I chose public health, mainly because.
- I chose public health because.
- My reason for choosing public health
is really deeply rooted in
my personal experiences.
- Many things led me to public health.
- Having worked as a physician in a low
and middle income country,
participating in work in
public health allowed me
to see that we can treat people
or we can address the needs of the people,
not just one patient at a time,
but in the community as a whole
and that for me was very valuable
'cause working in public health allowed me
to integrate environmental engineering,
medicine and public health
and see it in a more impactful way.
- I remember my family,
we moved from Detroit
to a suburban area outside of the city.
And while I was young at the time,
I really couldn't ignore
the stark differences
and racial demographics,
but also urban development
and it really sparked a curiosity,
didn't know what it looked
like and meant at the time,
and how to really conceptualize that.
Now, understanding that move
that I had when I was younger
from those two desparate
communities, just 30 miles apart,
but had a 10 year difference
in life expectancy,
that stark difference was something
that propelled me into the field.
- I graduated the year
that Covid-19 pandemic hit.
So who were the frontline
workers during the pandemic?
It was people like my parents.
It was people like those
in my Cuban community,
immigrant community, Latina
community that were still pushed
to or had to go to work and
expose themselves to Covid-19
and I had already seen people's social
and behavioral risk factors
for certain chronic diseases
that just made worse during
the Covid-19 pandemic,
in my own family and in my community
and that's why I came
back to graduate school,
to get my master's in public health
because I feel like I can
hopefully be a mouthpiece
for my community.
- I have been doing HIV
projects for almost 10 years,
and my work has always
been community-based.
Just seeing that human
side is so important
in terms of designing projects
that are actually gonna
benefit the populations
we're trying to serve.
Public health isn't just
about health outcomes.
It's about analyzing our society
and the environment that we are a part of
and seeing how that has
an impact on our health.
- It's one of the fields that I really,
I feel like can alleviate human suffering,
which is something that
I'm passionate about.
- What's really important
about public health
is it's really the bedrock of everything
and it really has components
in almost everything here.
So if we think of all the schools at Yale,
Public Health has a component
within each and every school.
(inspiring music)